estos movimientos sociales tienen su
Génesis en las organizaciones piqueteras
que surgieron en el contexto de la gran
crisis de 2001-2002 en Argentina en ese
contexto habían llegado a representar
ocupado un lugar que no estaban ocupando
los sindicatos tradicionales porque
empezaron a darle voz a justamente
personas que no estaban empleadas con
empleos formales que estaban desocupadas
en una época de grandes ocupación bueno
estos movimientos estas organizaciones
sociales se han ido consolidando e
institucionalizando a lo largo de los
años además de tener comedores populares
de organizar y movilizar a esta gente
como la que está aquí presente también
ha empezado a ocupar un rol hace unos
años de encargarse de distribuir los
planes sociales que entrega el estado de
nacional y es ahí donde hay una fricción
y justamente explica esta manifestación
porque están demandando que haya más
planes sociales y que no haya recorte y
en ese contexto señalan al acuerdo con
el fondo monetario internacional como
responsable de estar detrás de esta
situación de este momento de ajuste que
se vive en Argentina también están
exigiendo más alimentos y más apoyo para
comedores y merenderos populares